[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 votre
émission pour terminer la journée de la
meilleure des manières dans les yvelines
installez vous confortablement dans
votre canapé voici le sommaire
son ascension s'est poursuivi cette
année l'illinois emilie boulard s'est
installé en équipe de france féminine de
rugby l'arrière originaire de
rambouillet compte 11 sélections et 5
essais avec les bleus suffisant pour
s'envoler en octobre en nouvelle zélande
et disputer la coupe du monde elle est
notre invité c'est un emblème de
chanteloup-les-vignes la compagnie des
contraire est au coeur d'un documentaire
la réalisatrice léa rinaldi retrace
l'histoire de l'association fondée par
noah tomasi et nous avons assisté à
l'avant-première à versailles et puis
nous nous envolerons dans le ciel
yvelinois l'airplay ben de versailles
propose des baptêmes de l'air et des
vols d'initiation ça se passe à
l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école nos
journalistes ont pu s'essayer au
pilotage voulait compris plein de choses
au menu de cette émission avec les
journalistes de la rédaction de télé 78
qui sont avec moi en plateau miquel et
demi d'euros bonjour bonjour on va se
piquer l'english du côté d'une école à
la sauce british tout à l'heure et saufs
course en prendra la direction de
croissy sur seine pour parler de cette
école qui s'appelle l' english la
british school voilà tout simplement en
face de vous on en parle tout à l'heure
et en face de vous il ya nicolas landry
aussi de la rédaction en jaune il a
plein de choses aussi au menu vous allez
nous parler notamment de ce documentaire
que je vous citais en titre est notre
invité dans un instant c'est emilie
boulard emilie boulard alors on va avoir
de l'émotion avec le documentaire et
puis on va basculer dans le monde de
l'ovalie dans quelques minutes et des
découvertes aussi un agriculture
régénérative la maison raymond devos qui
est installée du côté de chevreuse nos
conseils pour éviter les piqûres de
moustiques ça tombe bien en été ils sont
nombreux les moustiques ne pipa ils
mordent ce sont des zombies des zombies
qui ont envahi le le labyrinthe un
labyrinthe du côté de joueurs pour
chartres astt un champ de maïs même très
exactement où vous en dit plus tout à
l'heure dans cette émission
[Musique]
mais avant cela mathilde francou est
avec nous bonjour mathilde on va voir
les événements à ne pas manquer cet été
sur le territoire des yvelines il est
tout beau il est tout neuf cet été les
yvelinois peuvent monter à bord d'un
nouveau tramway c'est le thé 13
exactement grégory inauguré
officiellement début juillet le nouveau
tram t13 relie saint cyr l'école à saint
germain les en 30 minutes sa spécificité
il roule à 100 km/heure sur certaines
portions comme un train puis ralentit à
30 km/heure un vil et passe en mode
tramway voici les propos recueillis par
julien leroy lors de l'inauguration tout
à l'heure je voyais un jeune homme qui
me disaient qu'ils habitaient mareil
marly et qu'il avait un bus toutes les
heures quand je l'aï leur agrément et
oncle en dix minutes donc vous imaginez
si la pollution en moi c'est la qualité
de vie en plus et c'est j'allais dire la
qualité de vie de la grande ville dans
un département qui est beaucoup plus
rural qu'urbain l'inauguration a été
perturbée par des riverains qui ont
manifesté contre les nuisances sonores
provoquées par le thé 13ème qu'à propos
de ce chantier qui est désormais
terminée puisqu'il est effective ce tte
13 dans les yvelines alors y'a d'autres
chantiers à venir eux cet été un
département des yvelines profitent de
cette période estivale pour réaliser des
travaux sur ces routes au total 69
chantier dans 70 communes des yvelines
sont prévues cet été sécurisation
modernisation aménagements le chantier
phare de cet été le pont de la 2e
division blindée entre maisons laffitte
et sartrouville sur la rd 308 attention
ces travaux peuvent perturber votre âge
et retrouver la liste complète des
chantiers sur le site du département
plusieurs communes elles lancent leur
opération d'été plein d'animations à
prévoir jeux sorties ateliers c'est
partout et c'est pour tous les goûts
d'ailleurs oui grégory c'est le retour
d'été en sable par exemple à montigny le
bretonneux pour les trappistes cet été
le programme est riche également avec
des semaines à thème comme les jeux
olympiques ou encore koh lanta les
grandes villes du département comme les
petites communes proposent des
animations alors n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet de votre
ville pour avoir toutes les informations
soixante dix huit c'est l'ombre de
projection séance de cinéma qui seront
proposées dans le cadre de l'opération
les yvelines font leur cinéma qui est de
retour 78 séances sont proposées dans
soixante dix huit communes des yvelines
cet été à partir du 19 août jusqu'au 17
septembre se succéderont des dessins
animés des comédies des films
d'aventurés j'en passe le tout en plein
air et gratuitement pour connaître les
lieux de projection et le programme
rendez vous sur yvelines tirer info.fr
la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fait aussi 7e
art c'est au dessus effectivement tous
les jeudis jusqu'au 25 août les
visiteurs pourront découvrir ou
redécouvrir un film sous un ciel étoilé
au programme sos fantômes l'appel de la
forêt ou encore l'animé le château
ambulant
là encore c'est totalement gratuit plus
d'informations sur le site de la
commande d'un montant de la musique quel
style nicolas miquel bojic trop
peu plus sport mais je mets un drapeau
cl bon j'aurais dû terminer vous nicolas
où ça fait la transition transition
électro en termine en musique après le
cinéma après tout toutes ces bonnes
choses de la musique avec le festival
électrique par qui sera aussi de retour
cet été à la fin de l'été ça pour même
si ce n'est pas mon style de
prédilection et bien deux jours entiers
de musique électro et se passer sur cinq
scènes au sein de l'île des
impressionnistes à chatou avec une
cinquantaine d'artistes dont bakker matt
martin solveig mr oizo ou encore the
boys il y en a pour tous les goûts
l'électrique parc se déroulera les 3 et
4 septembre merci mathilde on vous
retrouve tout au long de cette émission
pour une piqûre de rappel sur ces
événements à ne pas manquer dans les
yvelines où ne parlerai tout à l'heure
aussi de cours de pilotage parce que
c'est possible dans les yvelines du côté
de l'aérodrome de saint cyr l'école mais
avant cela notre invité nicolas elle
joue au rugby elle est internationale
française et elle connaît une ascension
qui se poursuit qui s'est poursuivie en
2022 est originaire de rambouillet mini
boulard à 23 ans aujourd'hui 11
sélections au avec le quinze de france
féminin et déjà cinq essais sur 11
sélections et d'ailleurs mais bath est
allé rapide 1 elle est rapide sur le
terrain mais aussi dans sa carrière
pourquoi parce que commence le rugby
qu'en 2017 elle est déjà âgé pour un
joueur de rugby et enfin relativement
parlant je veux dire y'en a qui
commencent plus tôt mais comment ce
rugby en 2017 à chilly mazarin et puis
quatre ans après à koné sa première
sélection avec le quinze de france
féminin c'était lors du tournoi des six
nations 2021 un premier match face au
pays de galles et pour son premier match
aller ce cri cet essai que vous allez
voir l'image emilie boulard élimine une
galloise transmet à maël phil hope on
déborde fixe hervé intérieur à camille
simard qui voit revenir une gallois sur
elle et donne à emilie goût là le long
de la ligne de touche levin oise aplatit
en bout line et c'est pour le quinze de
france 1 essai qui sera élu essai de
l'année 2021 par la fédération
internationale ou en rugby
d'ailleurs on a eu le meilleur et c'est
féminin pour une française est le
meilleur et c'est masculin pour un
français d'avions que nos damien peut
nous le clermontois qui n'est pas
hubinois mais voilà qui vous mentionne
quand même parce que c'est la génération
peut-être championne du monde en 2023 et
la question maintenant champion du monde
la question qui est sur toutes les
lèvres va-t-elle participer à la
prochaine coupe du monde de rugby
féminin se moquant tee shirt vous
reconnaissez la fougère direction la
nouvelle zélande pour l'équipe de france
féminin le 8 octobre donc du 8 octobre
au 12 novembre 12 membres c'est la
finale de cette coupe du monde on verra
si les français y seront mais d'abord on
verra on prenait le pari vitesse paris
le talent et je me lance et du coup
alors pour le moment c'est pas sûr mais
emilie boulard a été pré sélectionnés
pour participer à un stage de
préparation à marcoussis à partir du 18
juillet marcoussis le centre national du
rugby français et justement nous l'avons
interrogé à la fois sur cette
perspective de participer à une coupe du
monde mais aussi revenir sur ces deux
années en équipe de france et sur sa
saison à chilly-mazarin on les coudes
tout de suite
[Musique]
rando verte et de faire partie du groupe
élargi pour préparer la coupe du monde
et je renouvelle mon coeur donc
sportivement ce qu'on attend tous dans
une carrière encore plus à l'âge que
j'ai j'ai donc deux ans et je ne sais
pas où est le mensonge là et après la
wii clairement on va rentrer
pour recoudre préparation qui va
commencer
non je pense un bilan assez positif on a
pressé les dix ans j'ai fait tous les
matches et l'équipe de france j'ai fait
partie de toutes les faits de match où
je pense a déjà serré signe de confiance
de la part des coaches ça m'a permis de
progresser fortement dans mon rugby au
plus haut niveau de prendre quand je
sens en moi de rencontrer des situations
ou quand j'étais pas allez-y tous les
deux prouver c'est là dessus et après il
reste quand même beaucoup de travail
beaucoup d'expérience à acquérir et tout
mais je vais pouvoir du pour m'appuyer
sur ces deux dernières saisons au mieux
ça fait du coût 50 mais jamais jouer sur
un grand terrain j'avais jamais joué 80
minutes et coûte les personnes qu'ils
rencontrent achi les coéquipières c'est
grâce à ça que je suis là où j'en suis
actuellement et perdu connaissance de ce
que j'ai vécu pendant ces cinquante lits
nous ait décidé d équité h et du coup
pour la saison prochaine estimé à
blagnac je pense que du coup ce que
filme à apporter jusqu'à depuis ces cinq
dernières années dans le royal alors que
là je pense que pour les saisons à venir
j'ai tout essayé de partir dans un club
du coup de plus au tableau quel jeu pour
encore progresser je pourrais vous
confronter à des joueurs sur le type de
france
andy tu es de coupe de france et a
toujours envie de jouer en plus
du parti plus de faire une histoire
marquée par une
reconnaissance pour toute l'équipe de
france moi particulièrement parce que si
moi c'est moi qui ai bâti mais moins
marquée de jouer parce qu'ils soient
utilisés globalement c'est
[Musique]
non merci bien sûr emilie boulard pour
cette disponibilité on lui souhaite
d'être sélectionné parmi ces 33 joueuses
à la coupe du monde c'est ça vous y
croyez petit tour de table oui oui je
pense qu'elle a le talent est là
l'expérience acquise ce depuis ces deux
dernières saisons avec le quinze de
france alors cédé ton à destination
c'est forcément des grosses équipes en
angleterre qui est championne du monde
en titre au niveau féminin dans le rugby
donc voilà s'est frotté déjà aux plus
grandes il y aura un groupe relevé on y
croit michael franchement après un essai
comme à la marque et dernièrement
qu'elle était du plus bel essai de
l'année franchement je le reprends
directement dans l'équipe de france en a
aucun souci elle va gagner mathilde
émilie poulin sera t-elle dans les
sélectionnés pour la coupe du monde où
ils n'ont alors moi je suis pas une
experte me mais je dirais oui allègement
des charges bien sûr il soit c'est tout
le mal qu'on peut lui souhaiter au pays
du rugby le pays est un pays que vous
chérissez c'est bien sûr la nouvelle
zélande on va poursuivre cette émission
en parlant d'une association
emblématique de chanteloup les vignes
c'est la compagnie des contraires qui
est au coeur d'un documentaire un film
réalisé par léa rinaldi pendant quatre
ans elle a tourné de nombreuses
séquences avec les acteurs de cette
compagnie immersion dans leur quotidien
avec les réussites et aussi parfois des
difficultés comme l' incendie du
chapiteau de chanteloup de cette
compagnie des contraire c'est en 2020
nicolas dans glee 6019
ccc voilà c'était en 2019 merci pour la
précision nicolas landry vous avez
justement assister à l'avant première de
ce documentaire c'est en compagnie de
justin razès
aujourd'hui mercredi 6 juillet à
l'académie équestre national du domaine
de versailles a eu lieu l'avant première
le repère des contraires c'est un
documentaire de l'oea rinaldi est sûre
la compagne et donc des contraires qui
est implantée à chanteloup est les
vignes est porté par année aux atomes à
6 bonjour à toutes les deux mais bon je
voulais avec nous alors je me tourne
déjà vers vous allez à pourquoi ce
documentaire si j'ai bien compris c'est
inexact qui est venu me voir oui c'est
une loi qui est venu me voir
dans
ma société de production et elle est
arrivée faut dire parce qu'elle arrive
et que comme le père un personnage avec
des bottes colorées des plumes aux
oreilles et avec une détermination
incroyable en me disant que elle voulait
documenter ce qui allait se passer au
sein de chanteloup les vignes et
notamment la construction du nouveau
chapiteau et au départ j'ai trouvé ça
quand même gonflé mais j'adore les gens
qui sont culotté et évidemment je suis
allé voir je suis resté quelques temps
en immersion et effectivement quand on a
la chance de voir ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur du chapiteau et la magie qui
s'opère on a envie de témoigner et
justement là vous parlez de magie
l'aider ce témoignage c'était de parler
donc de la construction du chapiteau
mais aussi de l'équipe de la renaissance
de l'équipe alors renaissance man parce
que à la base c'était une construction
en dur il y avait juste la
transformation du chapiteau des moussa
en chapiteau
qui appartenait enfin en dur qui allait
appartenir à la mairie des dons et vous
savez la résidence permanente mais non
moi ce qui m'intéressait c'était le
travail de négoce à son travail de mise
en scène d'urgence ont rapport avec les
enfants l'évolution des enfants et tout
le bien que ça leur apporte finalement
là où il n'y a pas grand chose et quand
on donne accès à des enfants à la
culture au théâtre à des activités comme
le cirque qui est très mal connue
voilà c'était ça qui m'intéressait
c'était plutôt le travail à l'intérieur
après l'événement la construction du
chapiteau c'était super pour suivre
l'évolution et c'est une espèce de
métaphores la construction l'évolution
développement la construction du
chapiteau mais oui c'était plutôt l'art
en action que j'avais envie de suivre et
justement les uhsa ce documentaire saab
alors il votera finalement mais ce
documentaire pour moi le plus important
c'était de registre et le parti de
l'histoire de la compagnie de contraire
pour devenir une étude sociologique
d'une communauté chanteloup les vignes
c'était ça vraiment l'objectif quand je
suis allé chercher cette merveilleuse
cinéaste allait rinaldi pour aussi
garder en mémoire une partie de
l'histoire de la compagnie de ma vie
aussi évidemment et comment la culture
peut arriver dans un quartier et des
venir quelque chose d'essentiel mais en
même temps on est en essai ciel être la
cible d tous les attaques possibles
justement je voulais vous demander à
l'oea c'est un tournage qui a été long
puisqu'il a duré quatre ans je crois que
vous allez débuter en 2017 pourquoi
autant de temps pour un tournage
finalement alors ben généralement je
prends beaucoup de temps notamment les
documentaires d'immersion parce qu'il
faut un temps d'adaptation faut
connaître les enfants faut savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on veut raconter comment
veulent raconter et pour ça je suis pas
une journaliste d'investigation j'ai pas
des questions précises ggp un message à
faire passer pour moi est important de
prendre le temps de réfléchir d'observer
et de laisser vivre les choses voilà moi
je tourne en cinéma direct et c'est ce
qui me semblait le plus juste dans cet
environnement que je connais c'est pas
voilà donc je n'avais pas imposer un
regard j'avais pas imposer ma vision
j'ai laissé l'histoire s'écrire voilà et
c'est que c'est vraiment magnifique dans
l'eau travail délai assez que
elle arrive pour tourner de la journée
et on la voit plus c'est comme si
vraiment c'est vraiment elle disparaît
en milieu là avec sa caméra là travail
très silencieuse il ya la capte tous et
nous on oublie que la sa présence est
pas du tout imposante et ça c'était
merveilleux pour toute la population qui
a peur de la caméra qui a peur des
images etc ça s'est passé vraiment
extrêmement bien on va redire un petit
mot sur la compagnie contraire juste
pour préciser votre objectif avec la
compagnie ce t2 si j'ai bien compris
encore une fois amené des gens
d'horizons différents temps le leur
amener la culture et on l'entend dans le
documentaire vous plantez finalement des
petites graines dans dans la tête des
gens et ça leur donne beaucoup d'idées
et vous êtes un peu comme la deuxième
maman en fait de ses enfants avec qui
vous travaillez est-ce que vous en
rendez compte de ça que vous êtes une
force pour eux kb sûr totalement je suis
leur 12ème moment oui je suis c'est
qu'ils appellent la maman du chapiteau
et on a un lien très fort très affective
parce que c'est vrai que je suis un être
humain d origine dans le travail je ne
s'y plient nains qui est terrible parce
qu' on est dans un quartier difficile
devant moi et qu'il faut donner des
repères il faut donner des limites
constant enfin mais derrière tout ça il
ya énormément d'amour dé bienveillance
et ils le savent et je du geipan
d'enfant j'ai une fille lou alain mais
je plainds enfin
toucher devant quand je vais parler
quand même vous en doutez de l'incident
qui s'est produit du coup pendant le
tournage la 110 en fait du chapiteau je
voulais savoir comment vous vous l'avez
vécu puisque c'était vraiment prendre en
tournage vous étiez là derrière votre
caméra vous vous étiez là parce qu'il y
avait la compagnie comment vous l'avez
vécu
moi j'étais au brésil avec un groupe où
des chanteuses mauvaise en train de
faire un projet on a su là bas avant de
prendre l'avion on a vu les images de
l'incendié mais j'ai vécu ça comme
quelque chose de très dur évidemment
c'est un grand traumatisme que nous
avons vécu tous un traumatisme qui
n'était pas du tout
soutenu ni assister au napa odyssée des
cellules de crise rien on était vraiment
largués alors moi il fallait que je
travaille avec les enfants traumatisés
avec les familles traumatisées avec mon
équipe traumatisée et le soir quand
j'avais le temps il fallait que je
travaille sur moi même qui était
traumatisée alors nous avons vécu
vraiment un grand traumatisme mais en
même temps on grand abandon et ça c'est
important de dire parce que les gens
laissés rend pas compte moi je n'ai
appris j'étais en terrasse dans le café
j'ai reçu un roi de sable données ou 5
watts à pau audio quand même on en voit
beaucoup
et là j'ai entendu byers et j'ai utilisé
son message clairement envoyé et me dit
léa le chapiteau en train de brûler
voilà en fait son émotion dirait qu'elle
m'a témoignée j'allais me gênait mise
dans le film si on reste ici dans cet
espace non merde monde
c'est l'un des titres qui ont assez
là et non on n'accepte pas la violence
en tout cas ce film on pourra le voir en
octobre 2022 en octobre 2022 il sort au
cinéma et on espère que vous serez
nombreux à venir le voir voilà super la
bassée noté merci à toutes les deux un
les lunettes
je le disais vous avez pu voir avec
justine nicolas le documentaire en
avant-première qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé bien c'est un film d'une
heure trente s'est on voit vraiment
l'évolution de la compagnie des
contraire elle a passé quand même quatre
ans avec cette compagnie les arénas dit
la réalisatrice a passé quatre ans avec
eux et effectivement moi ce qui m'a le
plus marqué c'est cet épisode avec l'
incendie du chapiteau en 2019 ce rapace
avait beaucoup ému dans les avait
beaucoup ému dans les yvelines ça a
beaucoup ému ce sur tous les acteurs
concernés directement et moi ces images
où je vois les enfants marcher au milieu
des débris de ce chapiteau qui a été
incendiée donc deux trois jours après eh
bien on voit que les enfants ne
comprennent pas en fait sont totalement
dans l'incompréhension parce que eux ils
prennent du plaisir au quotidien dans
cette compagnie ils s'amusent ils
s'épanouissent il découvre la culture
aussi un environnement auquel ils ont
pas forcément accès avec neuza tomasi
qui est donc une metteuse en scène
brésilienne et qui les prend en main qui
est un peu leur maman comme elle le dit
dans l'entretien est ce qui fait mal
c'est que les enfants ne comprennent pas
pourquoi il ya des jeunes qui sont venus
s'attaquer à ce chapiteau à leur
bien-être en fait on répond ce
documentaire qui parle de cette
compagnie des contraire cette
association qui est très très importante
du côté de la commune de
chanteloup-les-vignes implantée depuis
de nombreuses années merci nicolas lots
michael
hello hey oui marie
on va repasser peut-être à l'anglais
mais votre accent est pas mal un jour
assure ainsi nick alors sembler on a eu
du côté de chanteloup les vignes du
champion n'y étais là on va décoder de
croissy sur seine pardon sur cette
commune de 10000 habitants lier une
école qui est 100% britannique elle a
été créée en 1954 oui je vais continuer
en france effectivement grégory un écrin
britannique au coeur des divines sur un
espace de 3,3 hectares bienvenue à la
british school of paris la seule école
de france qui délivre le bac en anglais
ici plus de 600 élèves d'une
cinquantaine de nationalités étudie du
lundi au vendredi de 8h 45 précises à
16h sur un calendrier similaire au
calendrier à français les professeurs
sont tous du royaume uni ils parlent
tous anglais pendant la journée une
vraie à bulles anglophone ici dans le 78
les principales différences avec le
système français il ya beaucoup de clubs
et d'activités en dehors des cours comme
le sport la musique ou encore le théâtre
mais la principale différence se situe
sur vent au niveau du cursus scolaire on
écoute la directrice de l'école
secondaire on fait ce qu'on appelle les
gc fs les examens de gc f s les élèves
passent ces examens là à l'âge de 16 ans
et après ils vont faire ce qu'on appelle
les élèves advanced l'avons donc là
c'est l'équivalent un peu du bac et ça
ça se fait à l'âge de 18 ans mais il a
beau c'est assez différent parce que les
élèves qui ont entre 16 et 18 ans ne
font que trois matières donc ils
choisissent leurs trois matières
préférées et ils n'étudient que ces
trois matières là alors pour être
totalement dans les codes britannique
les uniformes sont obligatoire jusqu'à
16 ans dans la structure donc c'est un
peu comme on voit à chaque fois en
angleterre ils ont uniforme ils ont le
logo avec marc et british school of
paris on va justement écouter la
directrice de l'école secondaire
nous pensons nous sommes de l'avis que
un uniforme c'est quelque chose de
fantastique parce que
non seulement ça ne différencie pas les
élèves en par rapport aux vêtements qui
peuvent mettre si ça coûte cher si ça
coûte pas cher tout le monde il ya une
égalité entre les élèves mais aussi
parce que ça fait partie de notre
communauté et ça donne une identité aux
élèves alors pré-saison les uniformes ne
sont donc plus obligatoire mais les
élèves doivent quand même s'habiller
correctement pour venir à la british
school et jean par exemple sont
interdits il faut que l'atelier soit
formelle et clémentine et l'udc sont
dans ce cas mais ils ont connu ce fameux
uniforme on les écoute
moi personnellement oui j'aime bien en
plus celui-ci l'ait pas moche du coup ce
qui est cool mais je trouve que c'est
surtout c'est bien d'avoir de cette
égalité dans tous dans tout
l'établissement et de passe vous voyez
freins se lever le matin devoir choisir
pendant une heure ce qu'on va porter
parce qu'on sait pas et c'est cool mais
qui dit british school on pense
forcément à la reine elizabeth ii est ce
que la famille royale et est mise en
avant dans cette école oui tout à fait à
grégory le portrait à de la reine est
présent dans l'école il ya quelques
jours l'établissement a également fêté
dignement le jubilé de la reine
elizabeth ii ses 70 ans de règne les
élèves ont réalisé des activités pour
cet événement des portraits de la reine
ont par exemple été fait par les élèves
il y à ce lien également avec les
membres de la famille royale la reine
n'est jamais venu mais plusieurs membres
plusieurs personnalités sont venues
visiter l'établissement c'est le cas de
la duchesse de gloucester en 2010 de la
duchesse de wessex et de la princesse de
galles lady diana elle est venue le 9
novembre 1988 sa photo a été affiché
dans un bâtiment avec une plaque pour
immortaliser à ce moment mais combien ça
coûte d'étudier à l'école dans une école
à la sauce british découvert lors si
vous voulez inscrire votre enfant les
frais de scolarité vont de 18000 euros à
30000 euros selon le niveau merci
michael pour cette découverte des
découvertes il y en a tout au long de
cette émission et on va parler
maintenant de l'agriculture régénérative
ça vous évoque quelque chose peut-être
mathilde agriculture oui c'est pour
préserver les sols je crois que c'est ça
que vous validez les cultes risque
pour le coup l'express à ce sujet là
c'est vrai car elle a l'air bien informé
sur le sujet alors justement la firme
grand jardin qui est installé à
clairefontaine pratique cette
agriculture régénérative et depuis plus
d'un an c'est un mode de culture
différents respectant la biodiversité
des sols et on découvre tout ça dans ce
reportage de céline charles et de célia
400 go
silencieux et paisible c'est ce que
souhaitait ce maraîcher bio il a lancé
grand jardin en 2021 à clairefontaine en
yvelines romain viennois détient cette
ferme centré autour de l'agriculture
biologique de moins d'un hectare ils y
pratiquent l'agriculture régénérative ce
qu'on essaie de mettre en place ici
c'est un système dans lequel le sol mais
aussi l'environnement dans lequel on est
s'améliore au fur et à mesure des années
en ayant plus de biodiversité en ayant
un sol qui est plus riche à la fois en
matière organique mais aussi en
diversité de la vie du sol
et donc arriver à recréer un cadre qui
dont le la richesse on va dire augmente
au fur et à mesure des amis
petit exemple de ce qu'on peut faire par
exemple ici ça va être la sueur des
haricots
on met en place un paillage
organiques alors organise le mot peut
faire terme à face et c'est de l'herbe
[Musique]
un autre exemple de pratique on est en
place pour pour construire un système
vertueux c2c de mettre en place dans nos
cultures à intervalles assez régulier ce
qu'on va plaider des planches fleury
alors on va y mettre des fleurs qui vont
avoir plusieurs fonctions cette petite
succession alors de soucis pois de
senteur
capucine bourrage pensée a pour fonction
donc d'attirer les abeilles d'attirer
différents insectes qui l'a aussi vont
contribuer à construire un système qui a
équilibré quel saint leu maritime et
dans place également des rotations et
des associations de culture un exemple
typique poireaux carottes et il aime
bien être à côté il ya les vrais effets
bénéfiques de les avoir ensemble là vous
avez des carottes des poireaux sont là
il manque encore des poireaux ici les
oignons c'est pas mal aussi à côté et
donc on fait un petit peu attention à ne
pas avoir en fait la même chose sur une
très grande surface à 44 ans romain
viennois venait du milieu de
l'hôtellerie il a tout quitté pour se
lancer dans le maraîchage il a également
un gîte et organise des activités de
découverte de sa profession je fais très
attention à ça justement
d'arriver à créer un cadre complètement
préservée des gens qui viennent
d'engager tout pratiquer les activités
mais aussi les salariés qui sont à la
ferme
ni trouve un peu de bonheur et en
ressorte en 60 ans meilleur des séances
de relaxation et méditation en pleine
nature sont également proposés ici un
grand jardin toujours dans le but de se
sentir mieux en sortant des cellules
un turnover qui s'est effectuée dans
cette émission avec de nouveaux
journalistes qui sont arrivées mathieu
franco est toujours avec moi mais de
l'autre côté de la table justin brasier
bonjour justin avec ce documentaire
poignant dont vous avez parlé avec
nicolas landry il ya un instant sur la
compagnie des contraires et aussi celle
yaga tsongo bonjour on va parler aussi
avec julien dans un instant au bonjour
juste avec vous célia déjà vous avez
parlé de ce sujet d'agriculture
régénérative vous souhaitiez peut-être
revenir parler de ce sujet là bas je
voulais juste dire un petit mot à la fin
du sujet on voit les animaux il ya des
ânes des chevaux et même des moutons et
en faites pas ce que je dis pas dans le
sujet c'est que elles font partie
intégrante de cette agriculture
régénérative puisqu'en fait ils
entretiennent du coup les jardins et ça
évite d'avoir une tondeuse par exemple
ce genre de choses et puis aussi ce que
fait romain viennois c'est qu'il laisse
aux pousser l'herbe dans certaines zones
et donc ça permet de faire du foin et
bien sûr 2 bat toujours de garder la
biodiversité intacte et
d'avoir des insectes ou des oiseaux ce
genre de choses c'est lui annoncé une
charge pour cette découverte vous avez
accompagné pour ce sujet sur
l'agriculture et l'énergie je dise en
face de nous il ya julien leroy pour sa
première dans l'émission et massa
première en terme de reportage arrive
premier avec le reportage déjà pour tv
78 et dans quelques instants julien vous
allez nous parler des moustiques c'est
un ennemi de l'été un peu on va savoir
avec vous comment éviter les piqûres de
moustiques oui donnez vous conseille
tout à l'heure oui avec plaisir et je
vous disais il ya toujours mathilde
francou avec nous puisque dans cette
émission vous rappelle aussi les
événements à ne pas manquer dans les ive
et si vous nous rejoignez pas de panique
puisque mate il va voulait redonner
justement la première info le premier
événement à retenir dans cet été benoît
c'est qu'il est tout beau il est tout
neuf les yvelinois peuvent désormais
notée dans un nouveau tramway celtes et
13 il a été inauguré officiellement
début juillet le nouveau tram t 13 relie
saint cyr l'école à saint germain en
laye en 30 minutes sa spécificité il
roule à 100 km/heure sur certaines
portions comme un train qui ralentit à
30 km heure en ville et passe en mode
tramway voici les propos recueillis par
julien leroy lors de l'inauguration
tout à l'heure je voyais un jeune homme
qui me disait qu'il habitait mareil
marly et qu'il avait un bus toutes les
heures quand je l'aï leur agrément et au
p 26 minutes donc vous imaginez c'est de
la pollution en moi c'est la qualité de
vie en plus et c'est j'allais dire la
qualité de vie de la grande ville dans
un département qui est beaucoup plus
rural qu'urbain l'inauguration a été
perturbée par des riverains qui ont
manifesté contre les nuisances sonores
provoquées par le thé 13l le département
du doubs qui profite de l'été pour
réaliser ses travaux ses travaux sur les
routes départementales
au total 69 chantier dans 70 communes
des yvelines sont prévues cet été
sécurisation modernisation aménagements
le chantier phare de cet été le pompe de
la 2e division blindée entre maisons
laffitte et sartrouville sur la rd 308
attention ces travaux peuvent perturber
votre âge et retrouver la liste complète
des chantiers sur le site du département
vont pouvoir s'amuser également cet été
puisque plusieurs communes lancent leur
opération estivale avec à la clé des
jeux des sorties des ateliers c'est par
tous et pour tous les goûts tout à fait
c'est le retour d'été en sable par
exemple à montigny le bretonneux pour
les trappistes cet été le programme est
riche également avec des semaines à
thème comme les jeux olympiques ou
encore koh lanta les grandes villes du
département comme les petites communes
proposent des animations alors n'hésitez
pas à vous rendre sur le site internet
de votre ville pour avoir toutes les
informations
78 78 projections de films sur grand
écran des projections de cinéma qui
seront proposées dans le cadre de
l'opération les yvelines font leur
cinéma effectivement grégory 78 séance
de cinéma sont proposés dans 78 communes
des yvelines cet été à partir du 19 août
jusqu'au 17 septembre se succéderont des
dessins animés des comédies des films
d'aventurés j'en passe le tout en plein
air et gratuitement pour connaître les
lieux de projection et le programme
rendez vous sur yvelines tirer info.fr
mais la commanderie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines fait aussi le
septième art deux ans tous les jeudis
jusqu'au 25 août les visiteurs pourront
découvrir ou redécouvrir un film sous un
ciel étoilé au programme sos fantômes
l'appel de la forêt ou encore l'animé le
château ambulant là encore c'est
totalement gratuit plus d'informations
sur le site de la commanderie quand je
posais la question tout à l'heure à
michael et nicolas vos styles de musique
respectifs justin celui que vous
préférez pop rock pas probante moi
à moi plutôt r'n'b
années 2000
julien j'aime bien la variété française
bref un peu old school de foot
on est assez éclectique moi je mettrais
le rap aussi un style que j'aime bien
mais c'est vrai que j'aime bien tous les
styles est justement de musique il en
sera question alors plus d'électro que
l'électrique porte qui revient du côté
de château à la fin de l'été tout à fait
deux jours entiers de musique électro
espaces et sur cinq scènes au sein de
l'île des impressionnistes à chatou avec
une cinquantaine d'artistes dont bakker
matt martin solveig mr oizo ou encore
the boys il y en a pour tous les goûts
électrique parc se déroulera les 3 et 4
septembre le merci matif vous restez
avec nous parce que tout à l'heure vous
allez nous emmener dans les airs on peut
prendre des cours de pilotage dans les
yvelines côté de l'aérodrome de saint
cyr l'école va parler tout d'abord de
raymond devos ce nom vous dit forcément
quelque chose en tout cas vous ne saviez
peut-être pas il a vécu une quarantaine
d'années dans les épines à saint rémy
les chevreuse humoriste circassiens
écrivains musiciens on ne retient pas
tous ces talents vous êtes allés du côté
de la maison raymond devos à chevreuse
c'est oui c'est à saint rémy les
chevreuse mas saint rémy les chevreuse
on l'a visitée belge je m'en vais avec
célia et c'était très intéressant et
justement doit vous nous la fait
découvrir dans ce reportage nous regarde
ça tout de suite
[Musique]
bienvenue à la maison musée raymond
devos
[Musique]
c'est dans cette maison que raymond
devos a vécu pendant plus de 40 ans 43
ans ils ont acheté cette maison avec sa
femme simone en 1962 ils sont installés
en 1963 et ils sont restés jusqu'à la
fin de leur vie donc raymond devos est
décédé en 2006 c'était son souhait que
cette maison devienne une fondation et
devienne un musée et du coup c'est ce
qui s'est passé le musée ouvert en 2016
donc ici à saint rémy les chevreuse
qu'ici on est dans son salon ce qui
était son salon avec quelques éléments
d'origine vous avez le sol et puis vous
avez aussi cette bibliothèque qui était
faite par lui qui à la fin d'un petit
théâtre de la commedia dell arte et vous
retrouvez une petite partie de ces
livres et notamment vous retrouvez aussi
son meilleur ami georges brassens
ici vous avez quelques jouets du monde
du cirque raymond devos a découvert le
cirque quand il était enfant à l'âge de
4-5 ans avec son père et ses frères il
s'en est jamais remis il aimait tout
dans le cirque et notamment les
disciplines sportives du cirque il a
beaucoup pratiqué cette discipline est
en fait raymond devos était un homme
assez sportif malgré son apparence et il
a il a beaucoup pratiqué il était
funambule il marchait sur les 20 jusqu'à
plus de 40 ans et il a fait du
trampoline jusqu'à 80 ans
voilà ça l'à beaucoup saluent a beaucoup
servi aussi dans son art sur scène
[Musique]
ici on retrouve
derrière le rideau la loge de raymond
devos avec toutes ces affaires
reconstitué à l'identique
raymond devos était très ritualisé avant
de monter sur scène il est très anxieux
il avait un trac immense c'était très
important pour lui d'avoir toutes ces
affaires positionner comme ça et
notamment dans cette boîte avec ses nez
de clown il avait un petit rituel c'est
qu'il fallait essayer les signer avant
de choisir lequel était le bon pour le
spectacle du soir alors qu'ils sont tous
identiques
[Musique]
ici on est dans la salle de musique avec
tous les instruments dont raymond devos
jouait sur scène il était passionné par
les instruments de musique la musique a
toujours fait partie de sa vie depuis
qu'il était enfant grâce à ses parents
lui ces trois instruments préférés
c'était la guitare la clarinette et le
piano est ce qu il adorait aussi avec
les instruments de musique c'est elle et
bricoler les tordre un peu dans tous les
sens et donc notamment vous avez 7
clarinette molle qui est une clarinette
fabriqué avec un tuyau d'arrosage en
caoutchouc et puis aussi ce cor de
chasse qui était né d'une boutade de
georges brassens qui en parlant de
quelqu'un d'autre disait qu'il avait un
souffle a déroulé un cor de chasse du
coup raymond devos s'était dit comment
est ce qu'on peut transformer ça en
quelque chose d'intéressant et donc il a
pris un pavillon une embouchure et les a
reliées par un câble de gazinière pas en
doré
déroulé comme
on est ici dans le grenier raymond devos
était sa pièce son espace son antre en
fait et y venez ici pour créer pour ce
faire des journées entières
de création et vous retrouver en fait
tout son bazar créatif qui était
essentiel pour lui la voir sous les yeux
c'était très important pour partie comme
ils disaient partir du sol du quotidien
pour ensuite s'élever dans l'imaginaire
raymond devos en fait c'était un homme
passionné qui émettent tous tout
l'intéressait tous venez nourrir son
univers son imaginaire il aurait voulu
avoir plusieurs vies en fait il estimé
que sa vie était trop courte il aurait
voulu tout apprendre et notamment les
instruments de musique raymond devos est
un musicien mais c'était aussi un
écrivain un humoriste un circassien il
était tout ça à la fois et on en oublie
parfois parce que tous à sa forme est en
fait la totalité de son imaginaire
la première chose qui me vient quand
j'entends le nom raymond devos ça
m'évoque tout de suite l'humoriste mais
ça a été rappelé ses différentes
facettes il a été finalement l'homme de
plusieurs cultures il ya en tout cas
exercer dans différents domaines
exactement il faut dire et redire c'est
pour ça justement qu'on a voulu faire
découvrir sa aux yvelinois et puis même
à tous c'est qu'en fait pareil que vous
des gorilles moi j'avoue je connaissais
l'humoriste mais en fait il est
énormément de choses je t'avais pas que
c'est un sportif un sportif vraiment il
joue au trampoline jusqu'à 80 ans quand
même faut le savoir enfin accusé des
trampolines donc voilà une nourrice
musiciens circassiens et en fait c'était
quelqu'un d'accompli faut savoir que
d'ailleurs quand ils partent en vacances
ils partent et trois jours après il en
avait marre il fallait qu'ils retournent
à prendre c'est ce qu'on apprend et du
coup ce qui est bien c'est qu'à travers
la maison où il a vécu on l'a entendue
dans le reportage et ben en fait on
revisite ses différentes facettes vous
l'avez vu la pièce avec la quarantaine
d'instruments de musique c'est ces
instruments de musique on découvre son
j'appelle ça le grenier le troisième
étage où il ya toutes ces affaires et
voilà et en fait même ses madeleines de
proust pour ceux qui l'ont suivi on
retrouve des objets des sketches et tout
ça et même pour les personnes qui
connaissent moins comme j'avoue moi par
exemple c'est hyper intéressant ces
affaires intéressantes actuel qui les
rend si
c'est
oui comme comme tu l'as dit la maison
musée bas
si on vous faudrait suivre la visite
guidée parce que on apprend beaucoup
beaucoup de choses avec notamment de
nombreuses anecdotes faut savoir dans le
grenier jamais caché le travai message
il avait un petit lit alors c'était un
très grand sportif mais bon il pouvait
quand même pas trop descendre été remis
au deuxième donc voilà et puis d'autres
petites anecdotes comme ça on n'a pas vu
il y avait le bureau aussi donc une
pièce aussi assez central pour lui et en
fait il était passionné du dictionnaire
et tous les joueurs regarder le
dictionnaire
visiter cette maison
conseil en face il ya toutes ces
récompenses est vraiment en reste à
valider une très belle idée de sortie à
saint émile et chevaux cette maison à la
découvrir de raymond devos alors bien
sûr l'été on pense avant tout à la
détente on peut aller se balader aller
en extérieur julien sauf que l'été c'est
aussi son lot d'inconvénients un gars un
ennemi mois que j'identifie pour l'été
c'est le moustique il bourdonne la nuit
il est près de notre oreille à la nuit
nous empêche de dormir le moustique
c'est notre ennemi par excellence
justement avec vous on va voir comment
les éviter vous êtes un peu notre
sauveur dans cette émission vallières je
vais essayer de vous donner quelques
astuces alors on entend seulement niveau
vampire pas si vous l'avez entendu
autour de la table petit tour de table
tu t'es fait piquer parce que ta leçon
sucré et à la pause sucrée ce que c'est
le son du jazz comme ça non ça c'est
faux c'est une croyance commune mais qui
n'a aucun fondement scientifique en fait
les moustiques qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de détecter la concentration
de sucre dans le sang alors moi je le
vois quand je fais du foot notamment je
me fais un peu plus piqué que les autres
les autres alors mais pas forcément de
répulsifs et ce qui a une explication du
coup sûr pourquoi une personne n'est
plus sujette aux piqûres que qu'une
autre en fait l'explication principale
en fait c'est le don de la transpiration
en fait les moustiques ont la
possibilité de détecter grâce à un
récepteur olfactif c'est un radar à
odeur en fait ils peuvent détecter
l'acide lactique qui est contenu dans la
sueur il faut savoir que notre corps
envoie dans l'ère des centaines de
molécules olfactives
et le moustique peut en détecter jusqu'à
150 sur le corps humain quand même pour
les moustiques
vu là justement il n'y a pas que les
odeurs corporelles un quartier qui
attire les moustiques in an il ya aussi
le dioxyde de carbone dans l'autre camp
on expire en fait valoir la bouche en
fait les moustiques peuvent détecter ses
émissions de gaz jusqu'à 10 mètres de
distance voire même au-delà et en fait
c'est il ya plusieurs facteurs qui
peuvent augmenter cette concentration de
gaz carbonique notamment le surpoids ou
encore la consommation d'alcool vous
faut arrêter d'espérer alors exactement
et en cra sachez que la température
corporelle aussi une corde fine
température corporelle élevé à tirer
avantage des moustiques c'est aussi pour
ça que les sportifs et les femmes
enceintes bas sont davantage ciblés ça
c'est pour les causes de pourquoi on se
fait piquer par un moustique pour qu'on
attire les moustiques maintenant d
halanzy d'enfant même vos conseils
comment l'éviter ils en furent et bien
tout d'abord vous le savez sûrement mais
il faut éviter les sources d'eaux
stagnantes parme sur le balcon on a
souvent des jardinières qui reste rempli
d'eau après une averse pour leur dso
aussi paraît rempli d'eau ça il faut
éviter parce qu'en fait c'est là dedans
que les que les femelles vont pondre
leurs oeufs à la surface de l'eau ou
simplement donc sextuplé prolifération à
côté des rivières
et s'explique voilà c'est la raison est
aussi varié aussi l'astuce d'appliquer
des lotions répulsive sur la peau ou sur
les vêtements en fait les acheteurs les
agents actifs qui sont présents dans ces
produits bloque les récepteurs olfactifs
des moustiques et donc vous n'êtes plus
ciblés par contre attention c'est à
éviter pour les femmes enceintes un
autre conseil il faut aussi privilégier
des vêtements clairs car les moustiques
sont davantage attirés par les couleurs
foncées ses couleurs foncées et oui
en fait la chemise blanche ça passe mais
la veste leur rivalité n'était pas sous
les couleurs foncées attire d'appât
garde plus la chaleur et vu que les
moustiques sont attirés par la chaleur
il vient d'avoir ciblé c'est ça et aussi
bons riffs où il faut aussi opter pour
des vêtements amples parce que des
moustiques peuvent vous piquez si la
tenue est trop près du corps et
l'utilisation d'un ventilateur aussi
conseiller vous pouvez pas non dans
votre chambre blessé un ventilateur à
faible vitesse du coup le moustique va
peut pas lutter contre les flux d'air
est en fait il va il va pas pouvoir vous
piquez donc ça c'est une astuce
intéressante et enfin dernière astuce
voilà la plus connue peut-être c'est de
mettre moustiquaires sûr ça fait
nettement pour éviter que les biens
surtees intrus ne rentrent chez eux non
merci bien pour tous ces bons conseils
bravo parce que c'est une première pour
vous c'est que ce n'est pas facile on
peut y ajouter quelque chose donc
dernier halalisation ouais vous sachez
que ces seules les femelles piquent en
fait
pourquoi pourquoi alors je ne sais pas
quoi moi j'ai entendu peut-être une
légende urbaine mois sont soit le mal où
la femelle qui font le bruit pour en
fait divertir et en fait c'est l'autre
qui pique est-ce que tu ne sais pas
regardez c'est pas juste pour le plaisir
en tout cas qu'elle vous piquent la
femelle c'est parce qu'en fait elle vous
prévu une dose de sang pour noir les
tout simplement c'est eux voilà plein de
petits mon conseil pour passer un été
qui lui sera lent et liteo si on fait
pas mal de barbecue il faut le dire on
est en extérieur des barbecues je suis
pas moi j'aime bien manger et petit
merguez au barbecue je sais pas pour
vous sur la place et une pochette
chipolatas bas si
j ai reparlé pareil végétariens et du
coup de brochettes de légumes confits de
touffou
les conseils de julien pour pas que ça
devienne un cauchemar les barbecues et
éviter les piqûres de moustiques donc on
a l'image de la chipolata de l'année à
gaz mais aussi d'être en short peinard
dans son jardin pour réaliser le
barbecue on peut avoir aussi des
barbecues beaucoup plus haut de gamme
sous ce cas ce que propose le trianon
palace du côté de versailles nos
spécialistes en la matière et
spécialiste du barbecue à michael denny
d'euros et patrie jacques de dixmude
nous en parle
ce soir nous sommes waldorf astoria
versailles trianon palace pour déguster
un barbecue un peu particulier le
trianon champêtre
pour lui parler de ce trait à nos
champagnes de ce côté du chef alors chef
pourquoi avez vous voulu créer ce
barbecue ici bonsoir en fait c'était une
belle occasion pour nous de travailler
autour d'une offre barbecue en fait à
notre notre terrasse du bar c'est un
endroit qui est très vivant tous les
étés donc de mettre en place une offre
live cooking de cuisiner devant les
clients je trouvais ça très intéressant
d'apporter ça comme expérience au
waldorf astoria versailles et qu'est ce
qu'il ya au menu alors du coup alors au
menu on a travaillé sur une offre
intérimaire donc on a de l'agneau de
l'aveyron on a dû delonglée black angus
on a une poitrine de cochon aux épices
marine et épices cuisson lente et le
côté mais on a du poulpe des belles
gambas et un assortiment de légumes
grillés on a trois sauces barbecue
béarnaise une sauce chimichurri avec des
frites maison une petite salade verte
donc voilà si une offre complète on peut
explorer différents produits et on est
sûr d'une sélection de produits de très
bonne qualité et pourquoi le terre et
mer c est ça la mode moi ça me rappelle
le côté mixed grill en fait qu'on
retrouve souvent
à l'international pour nos clients ça
pouvait embêter de retrouver cette offre
est de pouvoir découvrir un peu les bons
produits qu'on adore et côté boisson
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve à vendre un
partenariat avec perrier perrier jouët
et donc on a travaillé aussi pour avoir
justement notre offre culinaire qui se
coordonnent très bien avec
la sélection de champagne perrier-jouët
est ce que ça fonctionne ce barbecue
champêtre j'ai l'impression que oui on
voit ça fonctionne très bien depuis
qu'on l'a démarrée le les clients sont
ravis réserve assez rapidement on
travaille sur des sur du matériel ophir
de qualité donc ça tout de suite un
cachet très très sympa au milieu de
notre verdure et
et oui ça fonctionne bien je vous laisse
travailler et nous on va déguster chien
et maintenant c'est l'heure de déguster
avec quelques bulles justement qu'est ce
que vous me proposez vous propose
champagne blanc de blancs ptz écoutez
c'est très bien
très très bon c'est mon péché mignon
[Musique]
très très bon
si vous aussi vous voulez déguster ce
trianon champêtre c'est le jeudi soir le
vendredi soir et le samedi midi jusqu'à
septembre et le tarif est de 55 euros
par personne hors boissons
[Musique]
après ce bon barbecue on va se dégourdir
les jambes du côté de
jouars-pontchartrain c'est une nouvelle
édition qui commence cet été le pop corn
labyrinthe revient en 2022 et célia vous
étiez d'ailleurs perdu l'année dernière
il dans ce dédale on peut le dire oui
oui je me suis perdue mais c'était très
très sympa comme activité et c'était
tout nouveau et finalement cette année
et leur ouvre donc ses portes avec un
nouveau tracé un martin a fallu bonjour
bonjour donc vous êtes le gérant du pop
corn la vie rentrent donc c'est un champ
de maïs en rappel de 4 hectares quand un
parcours environs d'une heure trente ans
que tout simplement les jeunes nous
rappelez peut-être le concept
cela vient voilà donc en fait on a semé
un champ un champ de maïs tout à fait
classiquement et ensuite on arrache les
allées pour créer un labyrinthe donc sur
quatre hectares pour que les gens se
perdent donc il ya environ cinq
kilomètres de tracé et donc le
labyrinthe est parsemé de jeux en boîtes
de jeux géants en bois ou d'énigmes pour
les petits ou le plus grand alors il ya
vous l'avez dire des jeux et des
activités aussi tout au long du parcours
comment comment ça marche voilà donc en
fait il ya des étapes il ya plusieurs
étapes et à chaque étape il ya des jeux
en bois pour les pour jouer pour
s'affronter ou des panneaux l'énigme ou
faut résoudre d une enquête ou des
énigmes ou enfin plein de des réveils
d'appel des conférences et les gens
sortent au bout d'une heure et demie si
l'on trouvait le code de la porte mais
alors cette année ce sont des zombies
tout à fait donc l'année dernière
c'était juste des jeux en bois ou
unanime classique là cette année on a
rajouté tous les samedis soir une
enquête criminelle et un soir dans le
mois de juin soit avant le mois d'août
et un sort d'un mois de septembre il ya
des zombies labit donc là le labyrinthe
est parsemé de zombies et donc les
visiteurs doivent pas courir le
labyrinthe le plus rapidement possible
sans se faire avoir par les zombies on
peut se faire mordre pour la journée
méfiant ça ressemble un peu aux
principes de l'escalier mais tout à fait
tout à fait des indices il ya des
indices qui sont parsemés dans
labyrinthe et donc faut sortir en ayant
les indices pour avoir les codes des
sans se faire attraper par des clowns
des zombies ou les poupées ou toute
sorte et on peut le faire à combien
maximum
ça peut être des groupes de plusieurs
personnes nous il ya des groupes alors
toute la saison on accueille même des
centres de loisirs qui viennent à 50
enfants et par contre pour la nuit de
l'horreur c'est des groupes de 8 à 10
personnes d'accord ok c'est au rsa qui
du coup parce que c'est quand même
horreur mais c'est accessible aux
enfants donc même les adultes peuvent
participer voilà ce qu'a aussi bien pour
les adultes en fait alors la vie de
l'horreur sont accessibles à partir de
12 ans accompagnés d'un majeur forcément
mais oui effectivement le public est
plus âgé onu de l'horreur que nocturne
classique ou aux jambes et ça est
différent des lectures de l'année
dernière ce live est une nocturne où
c'est une espèce d'enquêté criminelle
ils allaient dernière je crois voilà qui
tient donc le vendredi soir c'est une
nocturne comme il avait l'année dernière
donc lampe frontale et puis on fait des
jeux en bois hélas cette année on a
rajouté donc les céder les samedis soir
une enquête criminelle donc la fauv
aussi un peu pour les plus âgés on va
dire il faut essayer de trouver c'est
comme un clodo géo un trio d eau géants
le coupable le lieu et comment il est
comment la personnellement le colonel
moutarde
pendant le cluedo savoure ses
retranchements c'est quoi notre
adolescence je sais que c'est bon j'ai
dit
non on verra alors fait partie d'une
franchise et donc c'est la franchise qui
met à disposition des franchisés que ce
soit les jambois les enquêtes et les
différentes d'accord alors comment
participent comment on fait pour si on
va aller les nocturnes les infos partie
questions réservées la première
direction suédoise les deux garçons se
font forcément sur réservation donc sur
la billeterie en ligne après la journée
où les nocturnes classique vous pouvez
venir directement sur place d'un mètre
labyrinthe et sans réservation est aussi
toujours la petite bulle est oui il ya
toujours des snacks et cette année on a
innové puisqu'il ya des pop corn maisons
et des paninis et déco si vous aviez
suivi célia la fête des loges ça
l'intéresse piboulette scène maquis
toujours bien se restaurer après une
bonne activité se restaurer c'est
important parce que toutes les
informations les retrouve sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous et
merci de la marmite et merci bonne
journée alors pour fuir les zombies
justement je vous propose une solution
peut aussi prendre son envol allez dans
les airs et s'envoler pour la fin de
cette émission est ce que vous avez
toujours rêvé de savoir piloter est ce
que ceci quelque chose qui vous
intéresse je fais baptême mais à côté
donc j'ai pas piloter mais je trouve ça
super cool ça vous intéresse à vous fait
peur moi je peux pas du tout j'ai la
phobie des avions donc c'est très
compliqué là je pourrai pas peut-être
marre que vous avez déjà piloté martin
martin à paris j'ai fait baptêmes
d'hélicoptère mais j'ai jamais été
d'accord compagne et
ben justement l'aéro club de versailles
des livres des des types de licences
plusieurs types de licences et propose
également des baptêmes de l'air et des
vols d'initiation mathilde vous êtes
essayé au pilotage avec bixente mana
santisteva c'est bien c'est à fait on
s'est essayé à l'aérodrome d'essence
hier c'était c'était génial place et de
transit sur place on regarde tout de
suite ce que ça donne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me trouve avec tara bengué villa
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes chef
pilote adjointe de l'aéro club de
versailles derrière nous on a des avions
oui ce sont des avions sont pas des ulm
sinon ce sont effectivement des avions
il faut savoir c'est une association
donc l'aéro club il a été créé en 1911
en 1 150 membres dont 50 élèves pilotes
on essaie instructeur avec 3 mécano est
justement en vol sur cinq avions que
vous voir à peu près ici
[Musique]
on a 3 robin dr 400 et 2 sont accrus à
200 essentiellement pour de
l'instruction est donc parmi ces 50
élèves est-ce que c'est plus du loisir
est ce que c'est vraiment pour se former
professionnellement d'ailleurs un peu
des deux je dirais 50 50 il y en a qui
sont là effectivement pour de la
formation professionnelle et d'autres
c'est plutôt pour le plaisir pour
s'amuser et c'est si c'est un pépé aide
c'est un minimum réglementaire de 45
heures de vol
p t lc oui c'est une liste pardon c'est
une licence privée de pilotes d'accord
et 1 et l'apl c'est une licence privée
de pilotes
disons d'avions légers d'accord voilà
donc ppl c'est une carence et 45 heures
de vol réglementaire minimum et le l apn
c'est une trentaine d'heures de vol
devant terminé et vous proposer aussi
des initiations en des baptêmes de l'air
oui pour vraiment là c'est grand public
grand public tout à fait donc
ce qu'on appelle des vols de découverte
donc c'est une trentaine
unique de vol
sur un vol local avec
un pilote breveté on a aussi des vols
d'initiation à ce moment là c'est trente
minutes de vol
dans un cadre de l'instruction avec un
instructeur où on prend vraiment les
commandes et on s'initie à l'aviation
légère et du coup vous êtes aussi
instructrice puisque vous avez partir
pendant une heure avec un élève
actuellement avec
on est sur la partie navigation sur ce
trajet aller retour on va voir quelques
exercices bien évidemment
on fera les exercices de développement
auprès des exercices de panneaux
le déroutement de décontenancer quand
par exemple
voit que la météo se dégradent que l'ami
aéronautique arrive qu'on peut pas
arriver à destination on change notre
trajet on faisait route sur un autre à
gros gros mot mais bon je vous laisse
faire votre cours et puis on se retrouve
après ben merci
[Musique]
me trouve avec claude ça y est il est
prêt à partir en cours avec sarah depuis
combien de temps en fait vous êtes élève
ici à l'aéro club de versailles claude
cela fait trois ans que je suis au co
l'aéro club de versailles
progressivement j'évolue dans le maine
du vol or aboutir à décrocher la licence
et pourquoi cette passion pour
l'aviation passion pour l'aviation en
réalité je réalise un rêve un rêve
d'enfance voilà il n'est jamais trop
tard super et ben vous laisse faire
votre séance et puis bon on espère que
ça va se passer ça va bien se passer
normalement si vous voulez mais pas les
bains vol by claude et sa merci
[Musique]
voilà claude a bien pris son envol et si
ça vous a donné aussi une envie de vous
initier à l'aviation sachez qu'un cours
de vol est à partir de 137 euros et le
baptême de est aussi à 135 euros mais
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site internet
aéroclub tirer versailles tant qu'homme
ça donne envie en tout cas pourquoi pas
de s'essayer au pilotage or là c'était
une leçon que vous avez suivi vous avez
pu aussi vous montez à bord d'un avion
mathieu tout à fait avec bixente on est
monté dans un avion et même bixente a pu
piloter l'avion quelques minutes avec
basara l'instructrice et je sais pas si
vous avez vu sur les images nous on a vu
le château de versailles et c'était
vraiment vraiment génial mais c'est
prendre un peu de hauteur voire la
diversité de ce territoire des vignals
château de versailles qui est symbole le
côté rural le côté aussi urbain il ya
ait pas eu trop peur ça va dit shen té
pou rune piloter c'est passera rien
alors je pense que bixente avait un peu
quand même d'appréhension parce que oui
c'est y piloter moi j'étais à l'arrière
j'étais tranquillement installé j'ai pu
profiter du paysage mais je savais en
fait que ça secoue et énormément les
petits avions comme ça du coup j'ai pas
été trop surpris salle
j'étais va très bien mais je ne
débattrai
qui m'a beaucoup surprise lors de ce
reportage c'est je savais qu'il y avait
énormément d'informations à connaître
pour pouvoir piloter au niveau de la
sécurité de la météo etc
mais vraiment c'est très pointilleux et
c'était vraiment impressionnant de voir
lors du briefing entre claude et sarah
tout ce qu'il fallait vraiment connaître
par coeur tous les tous les documents
les dossiers qu'ils avaient pour une
demi heure trente minutes de vol qua non
et tout les toutes les procédures merci
en tout cas pour cette découverte bravo
pour ce reportage sa part rappelé que
dans les vignes à plusieurs zéros drones
vous étiez du côté de saint cyr l'école
on pense forcément aussi à
toussus-le-noble ville pour chats venait
également plein de possibilités pour ce
département des yvelines voilà c'est la
fin de cette émission 7,8 merci ma tin
merci justin merci célèbre maman
accompagnée réintégrer un plaisir d'être
avec vous et d'accompagner à les
yvelinois le circuit de votre émission
qui revient bien sûr très vite à
l'antenne et 10 il a passé un bel été
sur tv 78
[Musique]
et
ouf
[Musique]